bien faire un petit jeu tant que le ni
oui ni non comment tu t'appelles
oui oh merde
le blind test alors là où je vois pas du
tout là c'est un morceau qu'on a fait à
deux t2 dans la tête que j'ai préféré
oublier
devinez qui je suis one en fait ces
blocs est tombé je sais qui c'était
bernard minet à j'avoue c'est doc couper
la radio au milieu d'une phrase est
inventé la suite le jeu alors en fait
[Musique]
ouais bon change le jeu ouais le jeu des
papes et bah moi ces ciseaux ouais le
ciseau il coupe la feuille le feu vert
moi je dis passe au vert maintenant 3 2
0.5 normal je préfère alors tu préfères
une marque de voiture pas ou ou toujours
peugeot évidemment placement des
produits effectués imiter les voitures
76 ouais bon ça c'est pas très joli mais
bon après c'est quand même une voiture
de facteurs donc ces jeunes gens de
pastel ray après bon on peut tricher un
peu touche est le cache cache derrière
le siège n'est pas où ce genre
les possibilités sont assez restreinte
quand même le jeu du répète que je dis
et si on s'arrêtait prendre un petit
café le temps que la voiture charge et
si on s'est arrêté pour le petit café le
temps que la voiture charge d'accord
donc le jeu c'est à peu près ce que je
dis d'accord donc le jeu c'est de
répéter tout ce que je dis le caca c'est
délicieux le cas castet délicieux au je
viens de me faire remarquer à me fais
pas ça je voulais aller on s'arrêtera un
petit café le temps que la voiture
charge à deviner la chanson toi mais
c'est ma chanson en fait sur la chaîne
n'a tout a donc tu ta promo sur ma
chaîne youtube d'accord oui
abonnez vous ah [ __ ] mais le manque de
respect le volley ball au
donc le schmilblick le schmilblick san
animal non une tortue manon 1 2 3 soleil
1 2 3 soleil à de gagner moi ils peuvent
non plus la whey est toujours compter
les voitures voiture jaune assez bien tu
vois tu remontes ça fait 4 à 372 pour
moi et ça dit que la prochaine pause
essence on a hâte ce jeu la prochaine
demande électrique normale cinq voitures
électriques ouais donc on n'y a plus de
fric en fait ah bin là on est l'argent
en amont 300 kilomètres encore à hiesse
tu veux je regarde on secoue la tunisie
continue à s'amuser c'est excellent ces
boîtes et rigolo critiquer ses amis
c'est pas vraiment un jour ça ah ouais
ouais bon et c'est ça qu'on est rentré
de dîner avec leurs potes avant de me
fouetter dans l'escalier ça bref encore
ni oui ni non
voyez une mini maxi effectivement avec
une boisson assurément les sauces vous
voulez un barbecue pommes frites curie
le second choix s'il vous plaît pas je
sais ce que vous prenez un ticket
restaurant en effet à vous aussi
oui perdu à jamais vous m'avez bien que
le schmilblick
bon alors là chimiques c'est un truc
dont on a besoin l'affection de mon père
n'ont cessé un objet une lettre de mon
père qui dira enfin kim m
jouer à cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha
cha cha cha cha cha cha cha le
schmilblick
et là il ya eu cette pièce de théâtre
quand j'avais 10 ans ou dans le public à
la place de mon père j'ai vu juste un
siège vide
ouais le schmilblick c'était une
fourchette voilà colin maillard et l'a
jeté plusieurs tout pour bien faire mais
repart et après les gars te retrouver un
outil web à ce jour pas le faire on va
faire le jeu où tu roules normal cha cha
cha cha cha cha cha le roi du silence et
consommer des substances illicites
ok elle est bourrée l'embarquent
monsieur on n'a pas bu d'alcool
on joue juste au roi du silence a quant
à elle passe ton violent parce qu'on
gagne après un retrait de permis peut
vivre avec un sens du coup ma faim
calme toi t'as pas le permis en fait
c'est un sketch pardon enfin si je
regarde en se conduit rétroviseur angle
mort
les mains 9h45 d'israël je peux faire
des petits créneau branger en était la
taille attendait on est obligé de finir
comme ça on pourrait faire croire que
j'ai vraiment conduire non ça pour ça
d'accord bon quelqu'un peut me ramener
nat
bon bah je crois que j'ai passé le
permis moins et merci d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à mettre un
petit pouce en l'air de vous abonner et
tutti quanti
je vous aime à la folie au revoir
[Musique]